the most too talented guys on the roster
fighting each other in their Prime I
think this is a sign where Dana's
literally he's over it he's over the UFC
that is no longer his baby anymore the
power slap Fight League is his main
focus this is more evident than ever
forgets the name of Maka chav the week
before the big the huge fight which they
haven't promoted he's been telling the
UFC brass to promote the power supply
League more because hope he gets better
numbers on tick tock
if you don't think he's over the UFC and
has lost passion you're out of your butt
because if you were still balls deep in
the UFC and you want to take it to
different levels and he weren't just
right off the coaches of ESPN knowing
you can get your check no matter what
you would be doing the Lord's work
trying to promote this fight of the two
most talented most skilled Fighters
you've ever had compete in their Prime
instead you're more focused on the power
slap Fight League you can't tell me he's
still
passionate about the UFC